hello and welcome to this video when
playing these out desert desert teach us
something like that with black and yeah
keep lifting points and easy points and
I'm not getting anywhere near 2500 where
I should be okay so he just gives me the
bishop area right it's nice nice of him
how do you play this problem just having
this right square I have absolutely no
clue what White's ideas on this game the
Hopi setup looks decidedly weird a
knight on c3 what is this doing
let's open up with e5 it's really not
good on a two he opens a table you know
hmm
yeah tough to say maybe have no good
move them but this is already pretty
comfortable to say the least
you know to bishops on a wide-open board
I also want to play a little bit quicker
than I did in the games before it was or
was a bit of a problem threatening to
take to take and play this which she did
not really take care to care off King
maybe just tried to win a five as well
don't really see how I mean I'm not
detecting this but I can double maybe
just see six then take this yeah
how to how what is the simplest way to
win
maybe c6 but take here Queen b7 not
clear that this really helps maybe
better go to an active square a 5 is
still attacked and something that would
be to also would be pretty ok
and we basically trade down everything
then ok so take this Queen f5 is also a
move that I have to keep in mind
Queen f5 broke f1 let's pin pin and
hopefully win appear
the show takes g3m cheb g3 it's very
very close to to winning but probably
not not quiet
Knight takes c6 is actually pretty
annoying Knight is some it's really not
also easy to play play against
and really unhappy him that that's he's
getting far more than you should have
gotten can just take and take on c6 only
move anyway I don't know what he's doing
here
[Music]
20 seconds it should
rather I want to trade this away to a
dissolve
ten seconds
I think I'm really safe there famous
last words
I could have been heartbreaking to not
win again
yeah I really I really did not get the
whole setup I mean if you take on f6 and
give up the pair of bishop you should
just play with if oh I think I mean him
this is pretty pretty harmless let's say
but I didn't understand that Knight c3
is this reott doesn't really belong on
that square what what is doing and then
a4 a5 and before it's just weekends just
weakens the dark squares and yeah I mean
he I must be already quite quite
comfortable did five if it opens the
pollution up and c4 looks weird and then
he was stumbling right into this I
really had far too much difficulties
than I should've had you know yeah I'm
okay with what I did
but here's somehow I must win really
quickly
okay look f2 is the killer because of
this didn't see it okay it still it
still should win but queen g4 was
special you know now it got to the point
where it was annoying
really queen g4 strong I didn't see it
yeah here I don't I didn't understand he
can just take and play here and this is
yeah I don't know this is a tough tough
position to win at least what was my
impression those pawns go nowhere okay
nice good he doesn't have the nicest
piece coordination but still I mean this
in comparison I think just loses
yeah it was a bit of a shocker this move
I mean maybe I can do this right this is
actually not a drill I was somehow
thinking it's a draw but it's not a draw
of course I can just escape okay rook b7
was winning as well but it was far too
close for my taste okay guys thanks for
watching